hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a fun logic test
which answer in this list is the correct
answer to this question
number one all of the below
number two
none of the below
number three
all of the above
number four
one of the above
number five
none of the above number six none of the
above
i saw this problem on math stack
exchange
and i'll mention my videos will make you
so smart that problems like this will
start to seem easy
but math is about constant training
just as marathon runners practice with
5k runs people who solve the world's
hardest problems practice with easier
ones
don't let the math meanies tell you
otherwise
in this videos you feature me i feature
you
i want to mention mental floss featured
one of my logic puzzles can you guess
the secret word in this brain teaser
check out the mental floss article and
check out my video
so can you figure out this problem
give it a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution
[Music]
so how can we solve this logic problem
we'll start out by evaluating each of
the statements
first consider statement 1 all of the
below
if statement 1 is true
that implies all of the statements below
including 5 are true
but if statement 5 is true
that means none of the statements above
5 can be true including statement 1.
that would imply statement 1 has to be
false
this means one is a self-contradicting
statement and cannot be true
so we'll mark that statement 1 cannot be
true
now let's skip statement 2 for a second
and consider 3
all of the above
if 3 is true
that implies 1 is true but we already
concluded one is self-contradictory and
cannot be true
this means three also cannot be true
now let's go to statement two
none of the below
if statement 2 is true
that implies statement 4 has to be false
4 says that one of the above is true so
if 4 is false that means none of the
above can be true
so if 4 is false since 1 and 3 are
already known to be false we must have
that 2 is false
hence we have that 2 is a
self-contradictory statement and also
cannot be true
now
consider statement 4.
if 4 is true then 1 2 or three has to be
true but we already concluded that one
two and three cannot be true this means
statement four has to be false
now let's skip statement five for a
second and go to statement six
none of the above
if 6 is true
then 5 has to be false
implying some statement 1 2 3 or 4 has
to be true
but
we already know one two three and four
are false so statement six cannot be a
true statement
so now we're left with statement five
none of the above
can five be true
yes it can
if 5 is true we would need 1 2 3 and 4
to be false which we already worked out
so there's no contradiction if we have
that 5 is a true statement
so the correct answer is five
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video
these math videos inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they already have over a hundred
million views but the math meanies
unfairly criticize them and spread their
negativity let's be extra positive to
cancel them out please help by
subscribing for free to get the newest
videos and watching and sharing all of
mind your decisions videos you can email
me a puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can also check out
my books which are linked in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support